I grew up in a very tiny little farming
community 250 people and so you don't
you don't dream about oh I'm gonna go
off to Hollywood and get into the film
business is it was like you know well
maybe I'll be a teacher I don't know and
so I went to college starting a small
college more at State College in
Minnesota and I I didn't really know
what to do you know it was a good thing
I went there and then I accidentally are
kind of accident I've tried out for a
play and it was a really good theater
department there and suddenly i clicked
with these type of people that were in
the theater I said these are interesting
and I feel comfortable here so I studied
drama theater and then in that you also
studied stage design and things like
that I never got a degree or in that
quit school after two years is just
started wandering around and i ended up
immigrating to canada because i had i
got a scholarship to study at the bam
School of Fine Arts and Dramatic Arts
and met people that were really
interesting and then you know here I was
unemployed no health insurance and I saw
Canada the guiding star of the north and
I went up there and it kind of got
involved in the theatre a little bit up
there and then my friend was a writer
one of her scripts was produced by cbc
television she got it produced by CBC
and it was about the the First Nations
people up there and so CBC came to me
because I'd been working with them a
little bit and said would you help us
out because I had contacts with the the
reserves and things ends it sure you
know what do I know sure I'll help you
out so I helped him with casting and
things like that and then afterwards it
was all over with and I didn't have any
other work I just asked you have a job
and they said yeah we do and so I
started at cbc television never having
been near a camera I had no idea what I
was getting into but I was right in
there and was a great place to learn
things and
and then from there then the independent
industry started taking off in Vancouver
and that's where I got in the business
up there I think it changes more
personally I'm not sure the it has
changed a bit but you know with
technology and things like that that
have come into it but I think as one
matures into your profession that's
where I've noticed the biggest change
that I the more knowledge you get the
more efficient you become and and the
more you delegate things and and also
with the bigger the project you get is
you get more mature into your career you
then you realize well you don't have to
do everything you have to let somebody
else do something and that's you know if
when you first start out in small little
things you're doing everything you know
and but i think it's personally it's a
personal growth more than then a change
i think has happened from the outside
for me it is anyway i think but the
technologies you know the googling and
things like that and when i started out
we didn't have a copier we had a gas
stetner as we call them or a mimeograph
machine
you